Do you have a big heart for the 25% roughly
of your population for whom Russian is a first language?
Because they don't feel it.
Well, why do you say they don't feel it? I mean,
I can go through a list of reasons they don't feel it.
Many of them feel that your determination to take down
all of those Soviet memorials to the war dead
from the Soviet past,
that that's a provocation to those who speak Russian.
First, they also look at the fact
you've now banned all motor vehicles from
entering Estonia with Russian plates.
In fact, Russian opposition people are saying
that's a stupid thing to do
because there are many exiles here who hate Putin.
You, you, you are mixing two things.
And the Russians who are living here,
we call them Russian speaking Estonians.
And Russia aside.
So what I want to say first,
in 1920s, the Russian population in Estonia was 3%. Three.
And by the end of occupation it was 30.
So it is not that they are having.
Are you saying they're not there for real Estonians?
No, no, I'm saying that those who want to be with Estonia,
who consider Estonia their home,
have applied for citizenship,
have Learned our language
and are part of our society,
which is majority of our Russian speaking population.
But of course
there are also those who don't feel that. Well, and.
And what is interesting is that uh,
those people who are Much closer to the Russian border.
They can see very well that the life on the other side,
uh, in Russia,
is so much worse
that they don't really believe the propaganda,
because they know it's better in Estonia.
But, uh, I mean,
for us, it is important.
Just one thing we ask.
Learn our language,
because this is how we.
How we live here, and.
And this is the way to integrate those.
And. And also
what I want to stress is that
even if we have different history,
we have a common future,
and we concentrate on that.